واهلا ومرحبا بكم في بلدكم الثاني العراق
هذه زياره زياره مهمه
وتاتي هذه الزياره في وقت
تتميز
بكتره التحديات
وظروف حساسه جدا
لذا من المهم
اجراء الحوارات
والنقاشات حول هذه التحديات التي
تهم المنطقه بصوره عامه وايضا من المهم
الاستمرار في
الحوارات والنقاشات مع
ممثليه المملكه
ومع معالي الوزير
حول العلاقات الثنائيه
العلاقات الثنائيه بين طرفين تطورت
في مجالات مختلفه هناك تنسيق كامل
مع الجهات المعنيه والمسؤولين في المملكه
حول السياسه النفطيه
وحول تنسيق بين البلدين ضمن اطار اوبك بلس
هناك تعاون مكثف
حول تبادل التجاري
والاستثماري ونتطلع الى
تزويد العراق بالطاقه الكهربائيه
سواء من خلال الشبكه السعوديه او من خلال
الشبكه الخليجيه
لدينا تعاون مستمر في المجال الامني
ومحاربه
اصابات المخدرات
نعمل معا لتخفيض حاله التواتر التوتر في
المنطقه
والسعوديه كدوله
ودوله قاعده
في الاطار الاسلامي
تلعب دورا مهما في هذا المجال والعراق
كدوله محوريه في هذه المنطقه
نعمل معا
لتخفيف هذه التوترات الموجوده في المنطقه
وحل المشاكل عن طريق السلميه وعن طريق
الحوار
تطرقنا الى عقد الاجتماع الرابع للجنه
السياسيه والامنيه اللجنه الموجوده بين
طرفين
برئاسه معالي
سمو الامير وزير الخارجيه السعودي
ومن الطرف العراقي وزير خارجيه العراقي
وايضا تطرقنا الى عقد
المجلس المشترك بين الطرفين اجتماع المجلس
المشترك المجلس التنسيقي العراقي السعودي
كانت هناك نقاش حول مؤتمر القمه العربي
القادم في السعوديه
والسعوديه تلعب دورا مهما
لاعاده صياغه العمل في هذا المجال
تطرقنا الى الاستثمارات
وجانب السعودي مستعد
لدعم الشركات السعوديه للاستثمار في
الاقتصاد العراقي
ومن جانبنا نحن نرحب بشركات السعوديه
وبالاستثمار السعودي في العراق
انا اود ان اشكر الجانب السعودي
لدعم العراق في استضافه
بطوله الخليج 25 وفي الواقع بطوله الخليج
تحولت من بطوله رياضيه الى
السياسه الشعبيه
والعلاقات الدبلوماسيه بدانا نتحدث عن
دبلوماسيه الرياضه وايضا ابنواسيه
العلاقات بين الشعوب شكرا جزيلا
لدعمكم وشكرا جزيلا لهذه الزياره المهمه
واهلا ومرحبا بكم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم شكرا معالي الوزير
وشكرا لكم على حسن الاستقبال وكرم الضيافه
وهو مع ابنائه دائما بين اخواننا في
العراق وانا سعيد جدا ان اكون معكم اليوم
وان اكون هنا في بغداد
لاؤكد مره اخرى على
عمق العلاقه الوطيده بين بلدينا الشقيقين
وعلى اهميه
تعزيز التعاون والتنسيق بيننا الحقيقه ان
العلاقه تشهد زخما ايجابيا كبيرا في
الفتره الاخيره بفضل
توجيهات القيادتين في البلدين ونعمل بيننا
وجميع المسؤولين في الحكومتين يعملون
بخطه وثيقه الى استمرار هذا الزخم
والاستفاده منه في تعميق
التنسيق والتعاون بالذات في الجانب
الاقتصادي والتنموي وفي هذا الاطار
الحقيقه
ندعم كل جهود الحكومه العراقيه في سبيل
تعزيز الرخاء
والاستقرار في العراق
والسعي الى تحقيق
الاستدامه في النمو والازدهار للعراق وسوف
نعمل سويا لدعم هذا والتعاون في هذا
المجال بالذات من خلال تفعيل مجلس التنسيق
المشترك والذي يعمل على تفعيل مشاريع
عديده وفرص كثيره وهناك مجال واسع للتنسيق
والتعاون بين القطاعين الخاصين بالذات في
بلدينا لتعظيم الاستفاده من الفرص المتاحه
العراق الحمد لله الان يشهد تطور اقتصادي
ايجابي جدا وهذا يخلق فرص كبيره المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ايضا في تطور اقتصادي
كبير نمو اقتصادي الحمد لله ايجابي
اقتصاد وصل الى التريليون دولار هناك فرص
حقيقه واحنا نحن الجرار لابد ان نستفيد من
هذه الفرص لما يرجع بالفائده على والدينا
ويوسخ الرخاء المستدام للشعبين وسوف ينعكس
ايضا ايجابيا على المنطقه اجمل لا شك ان
لن نحقق هذه المستهدفات بدون منطقه امنه
ومستقره وهنا يلعب العراق دور اساسي ومهم
في تعزيز هذا الاستقرار ولا اعمل سويا
بتنسيق وثيق مع معاليكم لدفع عمليه
الاستقرار في المنطقه من خلال الحوار ومن
خلال
تعزيز المصالح المشتركه
معالجه اي اوجه خلاف وهذا مهم جدا لان لها
بدون الاستقرار لن نستطيع ان نحقق الرخاء
الذي نسعى اليه
حقيقه المنخرطون سويا في هذا العمل
واشار مع ابيه الى استضافه المملكه القمه
العربيه ان شاء الله هذا العام وهنا تهدف
المملكه الى الحقيقه تحقيق دفعه جديده في
العمل العربي المشترك ولن يتحقق ذلك الا
بدعم طبعا الدول الاعضاء والعراق بمكانته
في العالم العربي ودوره الهام سوف يكون له
دور اساسي في دعم هذا التوجه ختاما اود ان
اقدم التهنئه للعراق على استضافه
كاس الخليج وما تحقق من نجاح كبير
وطبعا لا يفوتني ان اهنئ العراق على الفوز
وهذا يعني كان تتويج مستحق لكن كلنا في
الحقيقه في الخليج سعدنا بما شهدناه
تلاحم
واستقبال حار
للمشجعين ومثل ما تفضلتم كانت يعني
دبلوماسيه رياضيه جماهيريه بامتياز وهي
مؤشر لعمق العلاقه بين شعوبنا في هذه
المنطقه والفرص المتاحه لتزيد من تعميق
هذا التواصل وشكرا لكم معاليكم وشكرا على
مره اخرى على استقبالنا اليوم